when do you think the first human being
will step foot on Mars
you don't like timelines but is this
something and you're very much focused
on kind of the short term
of uh incredible progress that's
happening and that makes total sense but
there is the Mars plan that that was it
the origin of the commercial space
flight efforts
um do you still see and dream about that
day
let me be clear that I don't want to go
to Mars but um I do think if you're if
you're making me guess a timeline for
when humans walk on Mars
I even a year ago I still would have
said by the end of 2020 like the 2020s
decade you know
um so by December 31st 2029 I thought
humans would have walked to Mars I'm
starting to think
that's still too optimistic but I do I I
definitely think by 2040. like I I for
sure think that and I really think
it's it's just hard to predict that
curve you know that that project out
that curve we're going to go from
feeling like it's impossible like it's
feeling like it's enough you know it
could be another by the end of this
decade JFK type moment especially if
China steps up with the Space Race yeah
it could be like uh all right NASA NASA
kind of says all right this Elon fella
like really make this a gigantic effort
well and if Starship works out as
planned and as as NASA has invested in
human Landing system they're relying on
SpaceX to land on the moon SpaceX can
land on the moon they can land on Mars
now whether or not the life support and
the human considerations of of long-term
space flight missions and high radiation
and blah blah blah blah refueling on
Mars is a huge huge huge deal
they definitely could send a Starship to
Mars
um and land I ideally land in one piece
on Mars
as soon as they can land on the moon
they can land on Mars basically I mean
those two things are very in some ways
Mars is almost easier
if you can use because you can use the
atmosphere to slow down it actually
doesn't take that much more Delta V to
actually land on Mars than it does
because on the moon you don't have any
you got to first get out to the Moon
then orbit the Moon you know you have to
slow down every one of those is a
maneuver change then you have to slow
reorbit until it coincides you know hits
the moon and then if it's slowed down
enough to not explode when you hit the
moon so there's a lot of Delta V there a
lot of change in velocity
um Mars is actually by the time we kind
of crunch the numbers it's relatively
similar it's just a lot more difficult
like timeline wise and you know accuracy
and all of these other communication you
know there's a lot of other things
obviously involved I'm glossing over
making it sound easy it's not but
um
but you know I think if I think there's
a real decent chance we could see a
Starship vehicle land on Mars uh
uncrewed by the end of the decade though
end of the decade I mean there's also a
sociological element maybe a political
one where
I think you're allowed to take more
risks with Mars than you are with the
moon because we've done the moon 1969
yeah it's been a while so PR wise you
have to be much safer yeah with Mars
like everyone's like it's super
dangerous like super like so you could
take a little more risk 100 especially
with the with man mission